you mentioned something that's um meant
a lot to me
and a community you're involved with has
reshaped this for me over the last
decade what this
means and in fact it's become something
a drama i beat all the time it's idea of
you cannot do life without other people
yeah right
and i'm thinking of the the
women who call the show who have had
miscarriage number three
and if they get one more text message
from their friends
about the upcoming baby shower right or
if they see one more
woman walk through the grocery store
with this new baby
how do you have community
and not hold on to that man you've got
something i don't have because it feels
very
similar to the the art the artist world
you've got buddies now who have their
own names have their own labels and
they're heading out on tour and you're
just got your fingers crossed i'm going
to get that call
and then some other guitarist gets that
call yeah yeah how do you
how do you retain community how do you
retain
love with these folks and not let that
demon of jealousy take your soul from
you
oh does that make sense yes uh how did
you just described my 20s and 30s in
that question
or i've always just wondered from afar
there's just a bunch of guys in a bunch
of different bands and i know
if i'm sold a million records banned
x if i invite you guys out with us i'm
going to change
your family's financial position yeah
but i'm going to take them
i'd have a hard time not being like dude
yeah what about this guy you know what i
mean but that's i mean that's that has
that's
every industry that's everything every
it's every situation why do you have a
husband that didn't cheat on you
why do you have a kid that didn't get
leukemia i mean that's a question we ask
all the time
it feels particularly acute in your
world as
almost a daily occurrence how do you
have community with folks that you're
also kind of like man i wanted that
yeah oh dude i mean that i you know
i mean i i have a a couple mutual
friends of ours who have become
like i've watched i've watched a few
friends become legends
right you know like oh we were friends
and now people don't talk about you the
way they used to they talk about you the
way they talk about
paul mccartney you know and i have
followed you in the bathroom yeah and
we're the same
right i know exactly what you're capable
of right
you know what i've heard you when you're
pissed off and you know what i mean like
yeah
i know you but the whole world has said
we choose you right yeah there it goes i
mean
i think i lost a i lost a number of
years to bitterness
over that uh i want to say lost i mean i
lost out of
i lost out on the relationships i could
have had with people because i was so
it was so hard for me to handle um i'm
really going for it here aren't i
yeah is there a couch i can lay on um
but it's but it's true you know i think
it's it's so easy
to say you know i can't even talk to
that person because it's just too hard
for me because
i want to be i think i deserve it or
they don't deserve it or whatever it's
not fair
it's not fair i worked so hard you know
especially in america i think we have
this view that
if we work so hard we can we if we can
we can achieve it we get it
you know go get your dreams kids and
it's like that actually the math doesn't
work out there's only so many right
there can only be so many astronauts and
presidents yeah and that's
hard but at some point
you either again choose bitterness or
gratitude am i thankful that i get to do
what i do
or am i angry that i didn't get to do
what they did
because i got to do something that's
wonderful yeah and i will never
appreciate the wonderful thing that i
did get to do
you know because if i'm so focused on
what they got instead of me and um
is that is that a discipline you find
absolutely a discipline
it is a choice it is a wake up put your
feet on the ground and decide to be
grateful every every
single it's almost like i'm gonna run
every day
so that the day shows up and i've gotta
sprint
i'm ready yeah and it's it gets easier
yeah
because guess what it's it's a joyful
way to live
right it's actually really fun to enjoy
the things you get to do
and it's fun to celebrate your friends
when they when wonderful things happen
to them
that has become probably the most
mind-blowing thing of the last two or
three years for me
is how problem-centric how
hey how are you man i mean i'm fine it's
cold right it's this
and it's whatever and that's just how we
greet one another
it's hot it's so cold yeah we don't
greet each other with do things are
actually
pretty good right now yeah you know what
i mean we don't have a a an ethos for
that
and this idea of being able to celebrate
your friends
that has become the way i know that i'm
in true community with somebody
when i'm having a rough day and they
tell me something great and i'll
it's exciting to hear it and vice versa
right yeah
oh that's so beautiful though isn't it
but it is
i struggle with understanding beyond
time and
weird like we experienced some stuff
together we were on a bus for
six months ago i struggle with
articulating how to cultivate that
in just the average run of the day world
other than sitting down the gratitude
journal making
it a daily disciplined practice i mean
that's definitely you know
scripture prayer i mean i don't know if
this is can we talk about that yeah yeah
talk about anything you want to yeah um
but that's how you i mean that's where
it is
right that's it's that's where you find
that that's where you find peace that
passes understanding
and that's what you're really talking
about is is peace instead of
anger and jealousy yeah and when you can
operate out of peace and joy
dude you can do anything yeah then you
can really
do what you you know you can achieve
your dreams because the thing that you
dream
is loving and serving other people
and when you're loving and serving other
people
have you found i mean it feels like the
more you're focused on
other folks the more stuff
i don't want to sound all jay busy here
but the more stuff comes at you
what i mean it is not jpeg you don't you
don't do it for
the roi of it you do it because you just
hold life a lot lighter but the truth is
if you're the person
i literally i just had coffee with a
like a young singer-songwriter like two
hours ago
before i was here uh who's
got maybe some more resources than some
others and it's like i don't just
it's not happening for me you know and
i'm working all day in my house
just working on this stuff it's not
happening i was like i think you need to
invite other people over
and and who can you serve
make a list of people that you can serve
with your resources and your time if
you've got this
you know the truth is is like you're
going to work on their stuff you're
going to get better
they're going to get opportunities
they're going to call you to be a part
of it
that you serving your community is
actually going to be the best thing you
can do for your career right
but but if you but it's not to do it for
your career it's to do it because it's
the right thing to do right